ahora vamos a hablar de la convención de
signos para componentes pasivos tiene un
nombre muy largo pero es una idea muy
sencilla pero primero enfoquémonos en
esta parte de componentes pasivos
decimos que un componente es pasivo si
no crea potencia y tampoco amplifica
señales ok por ejemplo aquí tenemos un
resistor ese es un componente pasivo
porque no crea potencia ni tampoco
amplifica señales y los capacitores e
inductores tampoco lo hacen así es que
esos tres componentes son pasivos en
algunas circunstancias decimos que una
batería o alguna fuente de voltaje es un
componente pasivo porque es cierto que
crean potencia pero no pueden hacer que
las señales se vuelvan más grandes bueno
vamos a empezar con este resistor vamos
a poner el voltaje y la corriente nos
acordamos de la ley de ohm que nos dice
que el voltaje
es igual a la corriente que es y por la
resistencia que es r aquí tenemos el
resistor con resistencia r y algún
elemento en el circuito en el que se
encuentra este resistor le va a dar un
voltaje y este lado va a ser positivo
con respecto a este lado que es negativo
la pregunta que nos queremos hacer en
este momento es hacia dónde va la
corriente cuando el voltaje positivo
está de este lado y el voltaje negativo
de este otro en qué dirección fluye la
corriente a través de este resistor la
corriente fluirá de arriba a abajo o
fluirá de abajo hacia arriba y bueno la
respuesta es que la corriente positiva
va en esta dirección
esta es la corriente y así es que la
corriente entra del lado positivo del
voltaje bueno ahora vamos a dibujar otro
de estos pero lo vamos a hacer distinto
vamos a ponerlo del lado
es un resistor con resistencia r y el
voltaje a lo largo de este resistor es b
pero ahora vamos a decir que el lado
positivo es este y el lado negativo este
otro sabemos que la corriente entra por
el lado positivo así es que la corriente
fluye en esta dirección y esta es la
convención de signos para componentes
pasivos que la corriente entra por el
lado positivo del voltaje ok ahora si
quisiéramos dibujar la flecha por aquí
no hay ningún problema fluye en esta
dirección y estas dos flechas nos están
diciendo lo mismo y también podemos
dibujar esto para capacitores e
inductores si tenemos un capacitor por
acá
este es el capacitor tenemos aquí el
voltaje el lado positivo es este y el
negativo es este y lo que nos dice la
convención pasiva de signos es que
ponemos a la corriente positiva aquí lo
mismo sucede para los inductores
ahora vamos a poner el voltaje por aquí
- este es nuestro inductor y la
corriente fluye en esta dirección
de arriba hacia abajo entra por el lado
positivo del voltaje y sale del lado
negativo del voltaje lo podemos dibujar
de cualquiera de estas dos formas bueno
vamos a practicar un poco más vamos a
poner otro resistor por aquí pero esta
vez vamos a poner primero la corriente
digamos que la corriente fluye en esta
dirección y ahora la pregunta es cómo es
el voltaje en este resistor si tenemos
esta corriente usando la convención
pasiva de signos
si tenemos aquí el voltaje cuál es el
lado positivo
sabemos que el lado positivo es por
donde entra la corriente y la corriente
está entrando por esta terminal porque
la corriente fluye de aquí hacia allá
así es que este tiene que ser el lado
positivo
el negativo eso es básicamente lo que
nos dice la convención pasiva de signos
cuando estamos construyendo un circuito
si es un circuito complicado tenemos que
poner todos los voltajes y las
corrientes y esta es la forma como
hacemos las cosas para asegurarnos que
la ley de ohm obtiene el signo adecuado
para eso es para lo que tenemos la
convención pasiva de signos